[Music]
what is up everybody welcome good
morning how are you how you doing oh man
I'm I'm so excited for this it's it's
been so many it's been almost a month I
think that we've been we've been playing
this and I haven't been well you guys
I've been seeing you guys way I haven't
played it yet obviously seen as much as
you guys have but I'm excited to you
because you know we're all busy we're
all doing our own things and now I get
to dive into this a little bit with you
Ben yeah so we're we're going to be
starting because the the way that the
stipulations are we have to start the
game from the beginning yes oh by the
way we're talking about deaths just
right thank you guys did if you didn't
know when you clicked in but it's all
good we're gonna play from the beginning
I might skip some of the cutscenes at
the at the intro just so we can there's
a lot of exposition that happens and if
we want to see more of the gameplay I'm
gonna have to like move through it a bit
but exactly that's even better though
cuz then you guys get to see more
yourselves when you pick it up if you
decide to elements of surprise I'm gonna
hit the Go button
no I had to clear off all of my saves
from this lest the cloud so that I
wouldn't spoil or ruin anything by
accident playing game for how long like
it 90 minutes or so
Wow if things get wild who knows maybe
maybe longer if everything goes bad
maybe sure but and I want to have
probably is what we're gonna be looking
at yeah and I'm also here to answer any
questions you guys have up to the third
chapter I'm only gonna play on normal
I'm not crazy I don't have anything to
prove it's all good nothing to do here
yeah but has it exactly Randolph it's
been a long time coming there are so
many questions around this game and hope
that we can we can answer some of them I
want to try my best not to talk during
cutscenes but there's also going to be
time so I'm probably going to see a
question that I want to answer I'm going
to get excited and I apologize for it in
advance this is me covering myself in
case I mess up but I'll try my best
because we definitely want to get to
some gameplay and although you know the
cinematics are beautiful they're amazing
we do want to get to some healthy
gameplay also what day is it today it's
7:00 let's just say today a surprise but
yeah if you guys are interested in
seeing you know all the cutscenes from
the opening chapters and stuff like that
we do have some videos just saying up on
gamespot it's so true here we have all
of our content teams working really hard
to bring you guys as much good spoiler
free
as we can one of the ones that I'm
really excited for the response to has
been pretty good is our our chapter two
PSA which is just kind of like a just to
kind of give people a heads up and it's
that kind of stuff we're just want to
help you guys out we got our our quote
here from Cabo Wabo about ropes and
sticks a little bit of enlightenment to
help you on your way once there was an
explosion a bang which gave birth to
time and space once there was an
explosion a bang which set a planet
spinning in that space once there was an
explosion a bang which gave rise to life
as we know it and then came the next
explosion
[Music]
so the soundtrack in this game fits it
so well and the songs have been stuck in
the overheads
the old people have been playing it the
whole time it's mostly from the van low
roar but there's a lot of other stuff
thrown in there but it's a lot of stuff
that kind of sounds like this it
actually plays during gameplay like
walking think inside and kind of go deep
into the psyche here so like in this
game you're on your own super well it's
this is gonna be spoiler free inside of
like the beginning of the game like if
you wanna know absolutely nothing about
this game going in shouldn't be watching
III don't
I mean it in the most sincerest way
because I don't want to have anyone have
anything
[Music]
in the most
possible it's like if you're worried
about like oh no Sam's on a bike I'm not
gonna have my feelings hurt if you
decide
do not afraid of early
and up to chapter 3 because that's all I
can talk about you're good to hang out
[Music]
plus I don't think we're even going to
be able to get past the first chapter in
our lives
keep that in mind also there's still so
much more to this game than what you'll
see today I do have all the medical
conferences happening in the chat right
now very into that
[Applause]
I steer like did not really me
it's not just regular
it's like rapidly ages anything it
touches so if you have exposed skin
they deteriorate much faster than I
think this is like 15 or 20 years in the
future something like that there's a lot
a lot of real life - great
I think it's warning by the way Sam
loves her bike though gone forever
I'm trying I'm trying to fit in like all
the stuff I possibly can so we can show
it all off cuz this is where I get to
talk about the fact that Sam as a
repatriate which is his ability so
anytime Sam dies boy has to do is find
his body again
yeah so that's kind of a big part of the
game
just want to get some of a weird is
write me some black stuff okay
so in all the trailers is beginning we
always see the baby like that's all the
trailers start we're like go down the
row and then the baby's in there but yet
that weird doll thing in there this time
question mark already has so many guys
what about you if anybody else in the
chat has some questions about gameplay
or you know anything relate to this game
up to where we are allowed to talk about
it then let us know Ben is gonna help us
out with that
yeah also some some key people in the
chatter noticing that I I definitely
didn't do that fall on purpose that's
what we call rolling with the punches
real bad mess up into an educational
opportunity it's it's there's reason
behind everything after that
what's up Chris Ella welcome to you the
chat he says hi Persia hi Ben what's up
happy Thursday guys we're almost to
Friday Yeah right this is the actual
game this is the actual game I'm playing
this game and in front of you right now
another intertwining gameplay in the
cutscene a little bit but yeah what do I
think of the game Chris L asks I really
like it it's a hundred percent like like
a kijima thing and it's I love the man
but it's entirely up its own ass but it
actually does a really good job of
explaining things that you might have
questions about there's a reason for all
of it and everything within the game
kind of works towards helping you figure
it out there's a lot of reading that you
might have to do with like things you
unlock but it works out
yeah
do you really have to balance yourself
or you fall over no a lot of people seem
to not realize that you can just hold
both of the triggers and center your
gravity and you don't have to do that
back and forth nonsense the back and
forth nonsense it almost never pops up
if you just hold that's that's a big tip
if you're worried about falling over
with a lot of cargo just this is still
just the start of the game we've only
walked like 20s what the rain turns you
old that's what we're discovering well
okay fresh head and she's top to your
character I like her a lot
that is on the ceiling if I kinda ran
into her when we were driving our bike
and in the back of my mind I was curious
cut nails yes I really like
that deer was out
you also don't have to hold both
triggers for 40 hours that's you get a
lot of equipment that makes carrying
things easier I can't wait to see what
this game is like it already looks
fantastic on a ps4 oh but PC and then
mods mods are gonna be real wild make
all the packages actual Amazon packages
make real deliveries
whew
it's also a lot of time in this game I
was just gonna say that like there's a
lot of crying in the game everyone cries
it's like the captured my whole life
it's okay it's a big mood
[Applause]
yeah you guys feel a little faint figure
there yeah
people might not be able to see it on
the stream but there were you could see
kind of like the rain hitting
silhouettes of people that were floating
outside of the cave
we're crying I know but he makes it look
so manly
yeah so we're in the prologue boom we
made it what type of game is this it's
hard to put your finger on exactly what
it is which sounds again like some real
dumb like garbage nonsense I think
you're gone and it's hard to adventure
game do you need to grab you so hard I'm
not gonna talk too much because there's
a chiral allergy so you have dooms like
me I've got the extinction factor but I
think you got me be what's your level
you can see them right no but I can
sense I have l2 then what are you doing
here trying to stay dry same as you time
for setup my name is fragile yeah I've
heard of you that right
some reporter preaches
the man who delivers
[Music]
[Music]
well you know she's going to your
warning a crypto buy it a day keeps to
time for the lane you know you're gonna
hear every single sound all the
experience is the whole thing she's got
managed to be the mouth closed when I
come work for me
must be tough out here in your room yeah
I love the fragile Express had plenty of
people plenty of traders not much left
of us now save for a few and his folks
in the top of that
not much left of me either got soaked
for me to toe and I can't help you with
that
I make deliveries that's all edit into
town watch yourself
those things never stay gone for life
[Applause]
the time for fast-forwards whatever it
touches but it can't wash everything
away the pastor's won't Michael I'll see
you around some Porter bridges she's
gone yeah cool
so a lot of that stuff probably doesn't
make sense like what the heck is a dooms
what is I am doing as well if sex is
what makes you cry all the time
but that all I I'll say it all gets
explained as you later yeah you saw her
umbrella I feel like I lived in New York
for a really long time and everyone's
umbrella would look like that at some
point except probably way less effective
yeah just disheveled and broken except
pairs like super his neck oh yeah you're
talking about how the soundtrack plays
yes so wall while you do a lot of
important delivery is the sound will
drop
it'll play the soundtrack that just
works really well use your odor deck to
check
what the ground is like how deep water
is things that kind of perform you so
blue water isn't very deep yellow rock
surfaces are all
kind of slippery red you don't want to
be stepping on because it's steep and
slippery so you use that to kind of read
what you're doing you can
[Music]
so I guess the to go back to the type of
game this is I think an adventure games
probably the best way to describe it I
think only the rain shoes but then you
know that is a good question right if
the rain falls until the water why
doesn't the so a these are confused
[Music]
it's uh I think it's like as it's
free-falling before it like it's the
ground or something
[Music]
let's see the suit on almost all the
clothes in this game I'm pretty sure are
made out of plastic because it takes
thousands of years for the breakdown
that's just my guess I don't think they
actually address it it looks like the
boss so we're going up onto this
delivery site here another thing I used
to do in the or I know you said you post
me it's on my bike so I definitely don't
envy a guy do deliveries a day
throughout the delivery experience yeah
I really really like and they don't let
on
and I wondered the soundtracks like on
Spotify or something so sore No
songs recording songs too
[Music]
what a prime welcome back at the SIA I
think before they explain sorry I
instinctively just tried to pull up my
inventory to readjust my boxes cuz I can
already see that physically they're not
balanced right but you're holding the
trigger so right now I'm holding the
triggers you can you can tell cuz I'm
holding the straps on the backpack and
you can kind of like jostle it around a
bit but uh if if things are unbalanced
or I'm actually probably fine to just
walk as this is flatland so if you hold
it too much but anytime your stuff is
stacked really high or you've got it
stacked incorrectly it's it's better to
hold it so you keep your center of
gravity in yeah and we're also going to
get introduced to the idea of boy downs
which is exciting maybe we could do a
void out on the stream just the kind of
like show that off because I know a lot
of people didn't get a chance to talk
about it when they did their reviews
because I don't think a lot of people
ran into them
deliver our cargo
with all these smart drugs is their
stamina yes so there's a blue stamina
meter that will run out to thinking how
much you're carrying and how fast you're
moving there's also like a knockout
meter so a whole bunch of pointers on
meters had to wait out the storm
last month bike sounds like you've been
through the wringer luckily our goods
are in perfect condition well you did
keep us waiting
but everything else seems to be in
perfect order so great work we'll be
awaiting the next delivery and we've
done our first delivery do you ever get
a new bike in this chapter so no it's
not in the prologue you don't get your
first bike we actually have a guide on
that too for when you you get your first
vehicle your first bike comes in maybe
you like the sort of the first fourth of
Chapter two and you don't actually get
to use it as much as you thought you
would which is kind of a thing it's it's
helpful for where you can
we respond I think after after this
longer cutscene we might get to the
point where might start kind of skipping
a bit to get ahead this is the salsa
panel it's also in a trailer so it's
kind of cool to see differences which we
also have a video up for Igor bridges
corpse disposal Sam Porter I presume
right not the touchy-feely type Jacobi
said you had some kind of phobia thing
where you can't have people look I came
about connecting everyone where the main
character I can't actually touch anyone
that's deep oh it's gotta be a Okajima
you got silent poets and churches as
well doing music narrator
how long since he flatlined you don't
know the exact Tod but I'd say it's been
upwards uh 40 hours so it's about 48
hours that's it this is a suicide that
it takes for bodies to enter necrosis
there's lucky at all tracks beat who
knows let's go neck and is how are you
taking him
they turned into nuclear bomb to the
north the only way to take care of this
take on Twin Cities sure he can't use
another I wish I could but there's no
time then just burn the poor bastard
right here you put all that Kyrie Liam
in the air so close to town can't do it
better that trying for the incinerator
hey we can do this we just need someone
like you with dunes
I know it's churches I just like saying
Trevor cheese because it's got a V in it
well he's already in the first stages of
necrosis if we don't hurry this place is
a crater so how about it can we count on
you
then bridges hereby enters into a
contract with Sam Porter Sam just Sam I
feel that I cannot be teased that's why
we came prepared a bridge baby huh a
bridge baby with its helping you will be
able to stay one step ahead of them
there it is baby just beat me so much
time it's fine you're plugging into the
other side I'll roll out
Bufo says so Sam has a billion yes so
Sam has this thing called up it's like
like a catch-all term for it and the
universe is called dooms and his ability
lets him sense the dead people he can't
like see them see them but he can sense
kind of about where they are but fragile
can see them the fragile can see their
lover
but he also dudes like as a specialty
each person has a spherical Beach tied
to them and his is repatriation which
means he can come back from the dead I
won't go into country what fragile she's
also got one she's got two other
countries you can kind of see the come
out of the body because it's starting to
get into the necrosis state because what
triggers avoid out is when living
tissues touches like the negative tissue
of a dead person it causes just like a
weird chemical reaction point out
syngress leaves a giant showed up world
of the living and the dead all mixed
together
and that's when folks turn more of it's
starting to come out rapidly happening I
just really like that as seen with the
Gear Solid 5 with the sneaking
skull-face kind of where you're just
gonna stop watching it
also what other games will you hear
someone say son of a [ __ ] rainbow
that's enough of the selling point to
cut to the be teased
oh boy get up so basically though the
rainbow means that there's going to be
rain
[Music]
rain is of course it's time for bed also
signifies that there be T's in the area
also do they bring the rain wherever
they go and basically okay so we're
about to run into an area filled with
booties and a dead person
actually I think that it might actually
be made into installed on us get us out
of here yeah
thing
no nothing nothing
so I'm doing my best to like move the
camera in a way that makes sense here
because otherwise it would just be
staring arenas bad in this game
we got strand thing going on
the drivers getting nervous
so the defendant the guy has on my back
like orange spinny thing is best
motivator and where it's pointing is
where that person sits linked up to see
the ridge baby which
deceased and they canceled
that didn't work out very well you can
see John Cena in the scene one of his
rare occurrence is where he actually
shows up so yeah this is this is a scene
I think from one of the trailers but
this is the final version of it of
course
rich this is a bad situation for
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's Troy Baker
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a very big bTW yeah
boid out which is why he was struggling
to kill himself because if he kills
himself then it won't actually set it
off but unfortunately he couldn't do it
dang this is intense Sun of course Sam
because he's a repatriate comes back
only to see what he's about to see
No
he could see that this is this is the
beach
so different
situation
that's great bridges falling down
[Music]
now it's a baby
that's actually how bad they get an exam
a bang which gave rise to life as we
know it and then came the next explosion
an explosion that will be our last yeah
uh I'll try trying to like weave my am I
talking in and out of like when it
happens because we do have like if you
want to get absolutely no commentary at
all we have like walkthroughs up for it
yes we do
is this really hard for me to be on a
stream and not talk but I'm also I'm
trying so hard to not I know every
little thing I'm like oh my gosh
questions yeah I have things to say I
need to know but wow that's a lot to
digest yeah just in the prologue I'm not
gonna lie it dumps a lot of exposition
and doesn't explain a lot right from the
get-go and it's gonna keep doing that as
a heads up so when he was like hugging
the baby and it he basically like made
it evaporate into the other side of the
world is that what happens when he
touches people no he doesn't like oh
that was
I mean it's episode 1 noise crime said
we be able to live in the same world
accession so how does it feel to be back
in the world living deltoro don't worry
I'm a doctor well accordin aliy call me
dead man I'm well acquainted with the
dead not like you of course contrary to
the name I've never actually died I
would advise against that I'm no expert
but I can assure you it's for your own
protection
see so I'm a prisoner
these aren't handcuffs they're cutting
edge devices that keep us all connected
us
oh us yep bridges humanity's best hope
for the future or avoiding the
extinction if you prefer right where am
i what time is it watch me try pressing
it against your skin like this that just
means your body's got a good dimension
no no cops will watch over you 24 hours
a day that is to say we will we're here
to help
what are two days during that time we
took the liberty of collecting fluid
samples from you hmm
she thinks you're a repatriate that
makes you very special what happened to
the CD US central not was obliterated in
the annihilation
game over man that place is a crater the
only ones to get it continue were you
for obvious reasons and your broken
bridge baby that's it all right
it's been marked for disposal didn't
work anymore well I keep it we lost
everyone not just corpse disposal my
team HQ all of rediff word every soul in
central not City pink where at our base
in capital not city now or should I say
our new headquarters Sudbury seemed the
logical choice but our implementation
team has been decimated and there's only
so much they can do in two days
things here are a mess fortunately the
director and his support team were out
of town at the time so the chain of
command remains intact
I hate to do this so soon but I have a
job for you yes put us to work
need you to slam all six of those
monster energy things real quick stencil
is from when you repatriated I feel like
that product placement uh what's the
other mark from my clinging woman in a
cave hmm I see a fin Fossum phobia no
wonder you were out there alone where no
one could touch you I'll try to be more
careful Sam so the job is an urgent
delivery I need you to bring the
president some morphine what president
America's gone you talking about the
mayor of central ma no no no not the
mayor a miracle lives on Sam a president
is in the final stages of cancer in
critical condition but there's still
time why me
look Sam
do as I ask and I promise it will all
make sense why don't you do it because
I'm not really here Oh surprise
apologies this is just a chiral gram and
here come the tears allergic reaction to
the chiral transmission I'm actually
over in the isolation ward in the big
triangle building here is the morphine
bridge is hereby enters into a contract
with Sam Porter come on you got morphine
there what's this about tell me the
truth
the truth Sam is there America's last
president wants to see you in person are
you really about to say no
very good I'll see you in the isolation
ward
[Music]
okay so yeah it's do our next delivery
we're good to go take the smoking the
president
put this on my back all righty
we're moving so I guess this downtime
while I'm walking to to this building
just look up I'm not gonna be able make
everyone happy but how many people
absolutely don't want me to skip
cutscenes now let's take a vote they are
pretty long I'm not gonna lie there's a
lot and and we're like in the first
chapter so I expect there to be a lot of
legs catching up the story you can't
have gameplay for 25 having someone call
you on your phone so but yeah and I saw
a question earlier about the how the
multiplayer works so it feeds kind of
directly into the narrative of trying to
like reconnect people and basically any
thing you lay down to help make your
journey easier has a chance to show up
in other people's games so if you put a
ladder down to get across the river that
has some dangerous Rapids someone else
will find that and they'll be able to
use it
so it's basically just kind of like a
big helping helping other people oh dang
we're getting a strong though that's
that's very loud and clear yes thank you
guys I thought I'd I'd run it by you
guys again continue to do our best to
not talk over too much this is all kind
of inconsequential
well we'll let it rock then for you guys
see where we get
yeah so we're here and we're about to
get into another really long cuts grab
grab some popcorn
take a seat get comfortable and try to
keep our talking to a minimum again
it's well they're not saying anything
I'll answer dankey your question why is
it called best training des [ __ ] is
referring to an event that happened like
15 years before all of this is happening
that basically kind of wiped out a lot
of everything it's a bit of a post
apocalypse without being
post-apocalyptic but still is but the
death stranding is an event that
happened it's me dead man sorry my
mistake
I'm afraid the president's condition has
deteriorated thank you
this will help to ease the pain and
allow her to speak with you in his final
moments the first and last female
president of the United States surely
you remember her she raised you
you're not exactly dressed for a reunion
take that off before you come inside
I guess I could I could say that there
is there's more to the Deaf stranding
than than what I told you but there
isn't I can only talk up to chapter
three so I can't say more about it but
there is more so that's that's something
to kind of look forward to I guess yeah
yeah yeah kind of [ __ ] wears a hat
inside this guy I mean if I had a hat I
would be wearing arena that's the
president's right-hand man the director
of bridges the I heart man oh you were
with bridges one so I guess no
introductions are necessary
what's it been Sam ten years look at us
a bunch of deathless freaks meeting like
this yeah well good to see you too
president's waiting it's your mother
Bridget she's a bit out of it mud I know
she'll recognize you
Madam President we've brought Sam
we'll leave you two alone
so I knew you'd come back
[Music]
are you doing alright
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
Emily normally you remember Emily went
west took her three years to cross she's
trying to rebuild the country still here
Christian's letting people get a full on
about that full experience you're the
one I wanted to sense them I was running
out
help Emily she needs you
together you you can help us reconnect
you can make America whole Sam if we
don't all come together again humanity
will not survive
and we don't need a country not anymore
we do alone we have no future no
America's finished Bridget you're the
president Jackson said the thing
so you are willing to help me no I
[Music]
I love you Sam
I'll be waiting for you on the beach
Madam President
so see people talking about the game
engine while they're doing this I'll
interject really quick it's the main
game is on the decima engine which is
the same engine that they used for
horizon zero dawn then there are a lot
of cutscenes done by blur who is the the
studio that did the remake cutscenes for
the halo 2 remake they're very very good
yeah
was all I Holograms trickery but she is
dead for real that's action that's the
only real thing here houses mom the
woman who raised him is the the words
that they use but I figure out more
about that later on to resident is dead
if word gets out bridges is finished now
what happened here does not lead this
room do you understand yes director but
there's still the matter of the body
without corpse disposal we've got that
covered
Sam before she died the president made a
contract with you what are you talking
about as a member of bridges you're
gonna work with the rest of us to
rebuild America you think you can
recruit me like she tried to what she
succeeded look at your wrist
that's not symbolic I don't know what is
director
the cancer spread throughout her entire
body harvesting organs is out of the
question
and there is no need for an autopsy her
body needs to be cremated before she
necrotize this and if we don't this
place will turn into another crater what
do you want me to do we don't have any
Porter's right now and the CD team you
went into the field with are dead but
the president's body has to be burned
the road from Capitol not City to the
incinerator was compromised in the void
out and the only way there is on foot
through the mountains but the chiral
density there is off the chart it's got
to be BTS this job has requirements
Torme's repatriate muscle me why
Sam you're already on the clock already
making me have to go now get it done
Sam border bridges well yeah so I see a
lot of people which also trying to guess
who Bridget is supposed to be or
represent Bridget's her own character
all of those people you guys are talking
about are actually referenced in this
game indirectly so that they exists here
but they're not here it's keep an eye
out for that
can I have a moment
president strand believed in American
reconstruction ISM she worked tirelessly
to bring the nation together again and
without her there would be no bridges
she deserves a funeral with full honors
but we can't give her that if she dies
America dies without her bridges will
cease to be listen her cremation must be
carried out with the utmost secrecy even
if we pull it off what then who's gonna
take her place face it America's history
Sam
America isn't dead yet he just said that
it dies a Brigid dies she may be lost to
us but we still have an America worthy
of the presidency sorry why let's not
get into it now what matters is that
we're going to finish your mother's work
and rebuild America as she intended
that's the reason Bridges exists so take
the first step Sam and deliver the
president's body to the incinerator if
we don't
humanity will not survive you're the one
I wanted to send soon I was running out
I love you Sam
[Music]
I'll be waiting for you on the beach
body bag facilities into the southwest
remember that you'll be passing through
BT territory rebuild the incinerator way
up in the mountains so that the Carroll
matter in the smoke wouldn't reach the
city it won't be easy carrying a body up
there
this is also the first stirring you
around the block if anything comes up
we'll offer you support by the cufflinks
aspects like Noah
all right this is where you get
introduced to having to do different
like carrying a dead body is not like
carrying regular cargo ops rallies so
it's a thing to kind of keep an eye out
for and deal with you can't turn as well
[Music]
so what about other countries and stuff
because they're talking all about
America and how still rebuild a manatee
this what everybody else so many
question the world it's kind of got a
gotta play the game some of some of that
stuff yourself yeah I can't say that
though Joe brings up a good point you
can't fly things anymore the the chiral
stuff like gets up in the air and
apparently it just shreds anything apart
it gets up there it's like air
deliveries flight also very creepy
literally just staring at this wobbling
dead body old sign the head is like it's
freaking me out you know as soon as all
the sex positions over I bet it'd be a
great time to have a song play and then
have you kind of reflect on all the
cutscenes you just watched yeah wonder
if that will happen
have a pleasant journey he says after
everything we just experienced so far I
feel like there's nothing Pleasant about
the current state of the world yeah so
this is also when we first first start
to get introduced to the multiplayer
aspect so even though this is built by
an NPC it's kind of the idea of what
happens in the world so this watchtower
is a thing you can build in the game
I'll let you kind of look out and scout
stuff ahead but right now where we're
headed is we're going up to these these
mountains you can kind of like do all
this cool like plot of course stuff to
like wait points and all that but I
don't think I need that but it's good to
let you guys know that there's there's
the option if you are just starting out
and you don't want to struggle too much
figure out where you are you know what
I'll show it because it actually has
like a cool graphical overlay let you
kind of see where you're headed yeah so
if you put it down it actually puts down
a line so you'll never kind of lose
where you are option does he give back
pain he he does you have to stop in and
do a massage oh man little bit a
readjustment there yeah so this is when
you start to get into the uneven train
you gotta like ride the triggers a bit
oh man oh even got the name of the song
I like it yeah you know there's no
credit your artists it's very cinematic
with me yeah this is definitely some
self inner deep reflection music time to
think about my life you're like I'll
shoot okay let's let's deconstruct
what's happened I can't die there are
dead things my my mother the president
just died and she's on my back I've got
to carry her up this mountain
yeah the the jams are good though
is it fun it's it's a different kind of
fun and that that's one of the I meant
to say this at the beginning of the
stream
it doesn't convey well in just watching
cuz for you guys right now you're like
oh he's just walking and moving the
stick but while you're playing there's
more involved in like I'm watching these
rocks I'm like being attentive to like
the changes in dips and terrain it's
kind of the more detailed aspects of
just walking right because every little
thing affects him physically so what
looks like just me walking is there's a
lot more kind of going on and you get
that when you play but I I enjoyed it I
enjoyed it enough to spend 105 hours
doing delivery
for all these characters and I I wasn't
bored the entire time and I'm ready to
go back and finish up the rest of the
ones I got to do there's only one person
I never maxed the reputation out with
I'm gonna say if I like it's definitely
Mo's types games you enjoy' in-depth
storytelling you enjoy at the actual
like emotional and mental side of a
story and I began I can see how it
wouldn't be for someone who's like they
just want game playing action 100% of
the time with no real like thought
behind what you're doing besides just
you know going crazy it is a really
weird thing to try and explain but it's
there's more going on than what it's
also a game there's anyone out there
who's who's played like like mmo's and
just really loved exploring its if you
like finding places and things in game
worlds it's a hundred percent something
that you'll enjoy that's a real big part
of it sigh I love doing all that so now
we've got these these things over here
we've got cool letters to kind of walk
across this water with again just from
an npc leave a like alright I got the
one on there you get you can spam it if
you want you can't really do too much
from the outset that ways kind of steep
over there I'm gonna hit these ladders
cousin will also get to climb a rope
is there any actual combat because I
know there are like certain people and
gave me out to avoid or there is combat
so you get to experience a lot of the
like hand-to-hand kind of CQC centered
stuff for the first two chapters then
you get like a bowl gun that lets you
incapacitate people and not until like
the end of chapter 3 you get your hands
on some more intense firepower but the
game definitely doesn't encourage you
killing things because obviously that
means that bill they get stronger they
have a chance to come back dead and
there's also a chance that he'll have a
void out happen so that's kind of a
thing to man egor really helping us out
here he's really laying it out
we get all sorts of equipment I actually
think the game does a really good job of
kind of giving you more and more things
to kind of mess with like it gives you a
lot of really cool tools and gear and
the they kind of paste it out in a way
that makes sense so there's never a time
when I was like oh man I wish I had
something new to mess with which is also
pretty good
and we're coming right out for there it
is so that's the place can also yell out
anytime which is nice no one's gonna
respond though because we're not in the
multiplayer section yet but other people
will yell back at you that's kind of
cool
can you do deliveries with other people
so there isn't any like direct co-op but
you can pick up like I picked up a ton
of Greg Miller's like cargo that he left
out in the middle of nowhere and helped
him deliver them so you get to kind of
do that but there isn't any like join my
game let's do this it's all kind of not
not together
asynchronous yeah you didn't miss the
urination not yet we'll hit that up here
in a bit so we're almost to the point
where everything is going to open off
and there's our line right there
top secret by the president
so burning the body puts all of the the
chiral energy up into the air which is
going to make it which means we get to
our first blood in the water it's a good
what is still alive it can't be repaired
and it can't survive outside but the
decision has been made it has to go
direct or approve the order
oops it shut down guess we can't do it
sorry I can't finish this delivery
perfect but I need that BB so I can see
the beauties
a lot going on increasing my status is
[ __ ]
there's Tandy Osby from the bodies we
couldn't get up to the incinerator in
time comes with the territory I'm afraid
can you sit out the rain no they're
closing in on my position I have to move
for they realize I'm in here Sam if one
of those things keeps you it'll trigger
a boy down you all go back sure but the
surrounding area will still be a greater
I got an idea I'm gonna I'm gonna log in
to the matrix we're gonna get our way
out of here so that's how the the Mads
Mikkelsen stuff comes into place every
time you plug into the the BB yard
little memories
[Music]
there are a lot I'm gonna do my best to
not get caught I'm gonna call it now so
that if I I mess up I can't like talk my
way out of it but yeah so something I'm
curious about is like they'll show the
figure a little bit and it's standing up
and then they show the handprints are
their hands actually their feet so it's
it's like it sends out this like weird
sensing like like the bt's themselves
aren't the things that come after you
but uh also this is a good tip for
anyone who's doing this the only way to
see them is to stop so that Sam can
concentrate you can kind of help outline
them by scanning too but the the only
way to actually like do his like sensing
abilities by by stopping moving and the
odor deck gives you kind of like an idea
of how far away
faster spins the closer you are
I don't like any of this actually might
be alright now catch my breath she get
the stealth gameplay still that's that's
there Kojima is real happy about that
but how do you stealth pass things that
you can't really see that's the question
[Music]
what if you accidentally like graze the
little cord there is it only the
physical body of swing the umbilical
cords don't see me to alert them to
where you are they come into play later
oh right on top of me
oh they move around yes they they move
they that can hear and they can I can
sense so you've gotta like be as quiet
as you can which is what the the holding
your breath works like but the holding
your breath actually almost kind of like
a get-out-of-jail-free card sometimes I
may have actually done it yeah okay I
was a little nervous that I'd botched
the the first one cuz the kind of the
thing about the first one you do from my
understanding is that it's the the BB
isn't on top of it like they're not
giving you all the best information even
information you can possibly get cuz
it's supposed to be defective right yeah
yeah it's it's kind of in the weird
state that it's in I know right it's
like don't breathe but this machine is
gonna be clicking and wearing the see
the the BTS
they can't handle technology show us
what dying looks like all right if I can
get back we did that like minute one so
I can actually trigger a void out though
so I don't think people have seen that
too much I can try to make a b-line off
to the side to where I know you can
what we'll give it a go it'll be a
little out of the way but we're in like
the last 10 minutes of the stream anyway
yeah does a void out permanently affect
them like so as far as we know from our
messing around with it it seems that you
you actually make like a giant crater on
the map that stays there yeah we don't
know if it affects other people's games
though yeah but I I went through my
entire playthrough not triggering a void
out so I didn't actually kind of like
understand it entirely and then we
messed around with it later on
who comments a big part of the game
there was a lot of good combat and it
feels good to do too it might take out a
little bit to get to actually think we
got through this beginning part cuz this
is kind of like on the on the doorstep
of when the game opens up and is like go
and do deliveries you know the
beginnings more just to set you up to
have questions so that when you're
exploring it's like more rewarding when
you get a certain place the oh my god
this makes sense now or that thing in
the beginning makes sense now
which I like that oh oh you can double
jump that's a fun thing that for him and
he can double jump that was wild I don't
I don't think he ever explained why he
can double jump what hands [ __ ]
that's a real video gaming thing
I almost tripped on a rock that's normal
[Music]
this is a postman simulator I guess if
you want taking it like a surface level
yeah there is a lot of delivering that
happens
[Music]
through this middle bit
you also want to try to avoid submerging
the baby in the water there's the tip
right there thank you because it
stresses them out when you get to just
because you get to use it oh that's so
adorable but that's you that's you in
tins yeah
don't know was it shaken baby syndrome
it's a thing kept be careful babies are
fragile and gentle so enormous Norman
Reedus jumps IRL I believe it the double
jump actually comes in handy a lot if
you can imagine
all right I'm I'm gonna make it a thing
to try to get this this void out now I
might I might skip this next cutscene
just to get back into the gameplay it's
there isn't too much there but I think
what we have seen is good
I want to let anyone down if we did do a
cutscene now we'd probably have to like
stop in the middle of it and that's
that's worse than you guys do want to
check it out we do have I think the
whole of chapter 1 up on the YouTube
channel right now we're just gonna go
boy it out for the last five minutes of
the stream it's a lot of cutscenes well
like I said this is this is right on the
doorstep of them being like alright now
go out and do it bad about you so yeah
we're already coming up to the very very
end of our stream today's so we're gonna
spend this last few minutes to make the
void out happen and then we're gonna
wrap up Safa colors wrong for stealth
isn't that the truth before before we go
brooding right now oh there it is the
birthday cake so if you set your
birthday at the beginning they give you
a birthday cake on your birthday a
birthday cake happy birthday yeah thank
you
yeah that's the slammer monster and then
we'll head out and get it oh you can't
get you can't avoid it out with an empty
I love it it's all like post-apocalyptic
but you know what monster survived it
that's wild
he's really into it yeah oh cool let's
get out again school let's go get blown
up you know I put on my sunglasses to
perfect those are normal sunglasses a
normal person would wear I need to I
need to do a shower really quick
actually is it a requirement to shower
really this is their their introduction
to how showers work
I really want to love this game and
think it looks good but it isn't it's
it's gonna be a weird thing for a lot of
people but I think if the game looks
interesting to you you're probably gonna
like it yeah that's that's my only only
bit that I can do to recommend it is if
it looks good to you now before you get
a chance to do it you're probably gonna
like it if you're looking at what you've
seen and you're like this isn't it also
have to keep in mind this is the
beginning they're still like so much
more of the game posts just this first
shot their stupid name is die Hartman
all characters names mean something and
you don't learn about die hard manual
way later but they are silly actually
before we go let's let's do one more
thing
cuz we got the monster ad placement
let's talk about the other really cool
ad placement Assizes motorcycle sounds
to cover up the sound phone I am
planning to play this game because I
actually do enjoy like intense three
question Hartman I love you know we're
trying to go explode all right one
minute left
we could probably no yeah yes someone
ate a piece of the cake
you know cool great let me out let me go
do an explosion stop brooding it's time
to explode
I don't want final look at bebe that's
cool look at the kid
Sam it's dead man yeah poke it and let's
get on with it
looking good kid see you later keep it
up oh my goodness yes you all the
supreme it's really gonna make me look
at everything cool that's good we'll
just go through it this way yeah our TSD
that's your friend it's got blood in it
all right now I've looked at everything
there we go Li's private room let's do
it oh my god die hard man
he was waiting out there the whole time
talking to me on the phone he's sitting
outside the door like Sam I gotta tell
you about the suit okay okay okay okay
okay okay
we've just landed there we go all right
we're on the way we're not even picking
up the order we're just going time for
orders only got time for putting on my
sunglasses yes
it's very important we got to go out in
style off-limits not Brewis oh wait can
we not explode or do we need the cargo
to explode I'm getting ahead of myself
I seen you to slow it down patience
boy that's our cool and I don't think
anyone really sees them very often you
have to eat like intentionally okay take
worse orders for me take it good nice
got it
boom confirm skip those tutorials going
do you want to take this cool put the
smart drugs new backpack dummy you want
to let her take it
sure load it on the back little on the
back put you onto a rack go for it put
another one on the back go for it
more I've attached the suit got it auto
arrange nice looks good we're out of
here boom
also navigating the menus at the
beginning definitely willing to admit
probably not the easiest thing
see you later do you follow thanks for
tuning in hope you have a good one
you bet I'm loaded up all these ladders
I have looks like a noob Zack seven
costume from second we are ready to void
out I'm running straight for it and I
apologize for how quick in in sporadic
this last bit is but it's something I
definitely want to like try to show if I
can but I'm surprised that everyone
wanted to like to see the cutscenes and
do all that stuff earlier that was a
good time man I hope that hope we help
shed some light on and what this game
kind of has going on and if not check
out some of the other stuff we've got up
on the website or on this YouTube
channel the double jump is really nice
yeah there we go perfect uh yeah it is
time bring the rain every personal is a
problem no pressure
there we go the stalls are kind of show
what happens when you get got by a BT in
general since I did such a great job
stealthy run right into one
there we go finds you and then you've
got a life no more you try to get out
right now we're going to drag down so
the BT is going to take us to brag us
all the way to the big big be tedious
adult there we go so you get dragged off
like all the buildings of South amount
of grounds it's basically like a mini
boss fight we got head back to my body
over here we've got cargo on Oh who's
this is but we picked it up so we head
back over here it's in his stomach I
don't know
right and now where we got a raft there
is a giant crater and there's the other
thing that I picked up there's a giant
crater that we think stays there the
whole time and everything is severely
damaged yeah and you can actually if you
go into the map you can see with a
handprint
it's a giant handprint that gets gets
laid down so you can you can do that
kind of if you if you get caught by
diabetes this is what happens and
unfortunately you can't go inside of it
so now you have to kind of go around
yeah so that's a dangerous thing don't
recommend doing it but now you know what
happens and you can tell your friends
that you you know what happens when you
we're gonna rock the baby to sleep as we
close out the stream you guys thanks so
much for tuning in and checking out this
game with us today you know it comes out
tomorrow
exclusively on ps4 so if you liked what
you saw then consider picking it up for
yourself obviously there's so much more
to this game it is definitely a juicy
full experience game and you're gonna
need to do a little bit of investing of
your time into it but if that's your if
that's your flavor then definitely pick
it up thanks again for tuning in we hope
you guys have a great day and don't
forget every day at 11 a.m. Pacific Time
game spotlight is here we play all types
of things on this stream so I hope you
enjoyed it we will see you guys later
peace out goodbye everybody